BALL DO THAT.
PATTY MILLS TO MAKE HIM SEE
BODIES IN FRONT OF BOUNDS.
>> Mark: HOW HIGHTOUCHES TONIGH.
>> HE STABS IT THAT WAS MERCILE.
OHTTER THREE-POINT SHOOTER.
>> Adam: IN THE POST -- GIVE
>> Adam: BUCKET.
WATCH THTH
>> IF I COULD BE NG, AND RIGHT
TRANSITIONSHORT. FOR BRANDON
INGRAM FOUL ALREADY.
>> HE TRYING TO
>> ROBERT: HE PUT IT IN! WIZARD
UPSET ABOUT THAT CALL.
ZACH JUST PUT THAT BODY --  BUT
THE BULLS HAVE TO NOWHERE TO GO
AGAIN.
RE
THE OFFICIALS HERE.  BACK .NUAL
IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.IT WENT O
HERE COMES LONZO AND HERE
>> Chris: FIRST FOUL ON
DOZIER.
[ BUZZER ].
THEY ARE WELL-MATCHED UP
TONIGHT.BY DEMAR
DEROZAN AT HALF COURT.
GET THE OFFENSIVE REBOUND.
ZACH LAVI DRIVE.
LY PULLED IT.
UNDERSTANDING THE SITUATION NOW
SHE SHOOTS IT OVER.
>> Adam: DEMAR DEROZAN, ZAA
IN TRANSITION. FOUL .
I THINK THAT IS